Aux États-Unis, il y a 60 000 personnes
qui ont un stimulateur cardiaque qui se connecte à Internet.
Les défibrillateurs permettent à un médecin à distance
de donner un choc à un coeur
au cas où le patient en a besoin.
Mais si vous n'en avez pas besoin
et que quelqu'un d'autre vous donne le choc,
ce n'est pas une bonne chose.
Bien sûr, nous allons aller encore plus loin que le corps humain.
Nous descendons au niveau cellulaire ces temps-ci.
Jusqu'à maintenant, toutes les technologies
dont je vous ai parlé reposaient sur du silicium, des zéros et des uns,
mais il y a là un autre système d'exploitation :
le système d'exploitation originel, l'ADN.
Et pour les pirates, l'ADN n'est qu'un système d'exploitation de plus
qui ne demande qu'à être piraté.
C'est un grand défi pour eux.
Il y a des gens qui travaillent déjà sur le piratage des logiciels de la vie,
et alors que la plupart d'entre eux le font pour faire le bien
et pour nous aider tous,
ce ne sera pas le cas pour d'autres.
Alors comment les criminels en abuseront-ils ?
Eh bien, avec la biologie synthétique, on peut faire des choses assez chouettes.
Par exemple, je prédis que nous délaisserons
un monde de stupéfiants à base de plantes
pour un mode de drogues de synthèse. Pourquoi vouloir encore des plantes ?
Vous pouvez simplement prendre le code ADN de la marijuana,
des pavots ou des feuilles de coca
et copier-coller ce gène
et le mettre dans des levures,
et vous pouvez prendre ces levures
et leur faire fabriquer de la cocaïne pour vous,
ou de la marijuana, ou toute autre drogue.
Alors, la manière dont nous utiliserons les levures à l'avenir
va être vraiment intéressante.
En fait, nous pourrions avoir des pains et des bières vraiment intéressants
en entrant dans le prochain siècle.
Le coût du séquençage du génome humain diminue rapidement.
Il suivait la Loi de Moore,
mais en 2008, quelque chose a changé.
Les technologies se sont améliorées,
et maintenant le séquençage de l'ADN avance à une allure
cinq fois plus rapide que la Loi de Moore.
Ça a des conséquences importantes pour nous.
Il nous a fallu 30 ans pour passer
de l'introduction de l'ordinateur personnel
au niveau de la cybercriminalité, que nous avons aujourd'hui,
mais en regardant comment la biologie avance si rapidement,
et connaissant les criminels et les terroristes comme je les connais,
nous pourrions nous retrouver bien plus vite
avec des biocrimes dans le futur.
Ce sera facile pour n'importe qui d'aller
imprimer ses propre bio-virus,
des versions améliorées d'ebola ou de l'anthrax,
de grippe transformée en arme bactériologique.
Nous avons récemment vu un cas où certains chercheurs
ont rendu le virus H5N1 de la grippe aviaire plus puissant.
Elle a déjà un taux de mortalité de 70 %
si on l’attrape, mais elle ne s'attrape pas facilement
Les ingénieurs, en déplaçant un petit nombre
de modifications génétiques,
ont réussi à la transformer en arme
et la rendre beaucoup plus facile à attraper pour les êtres humains,
pour que ce ne soient pas des milliers de gens qui meurent,
mais des dizaines de millions.
Vous voyez, vous pouvez créer
de nouvelles pandémies et les chercheurs qui ont fait ça
étaient tellement fiers de leurs exploits,
ils voulaient les publier librement
afin que tout le monde puisse les voir
et avoir accès à ces informations.
Mais ça va plus loin que ça.
Le chercheur d'ADN Andrew Hessel
a souligné à juste titre
que si on peut utiliser les traitements contre le cancer,
les traitements du cancer moderne,
pour aller s'attaquer à une cellule tout en laissant toutes les autres cellules
autour d'elle intacte,
ensuite,on peut aussi s'attaquer à la cellule de n'importe qui.
Les traitements du cancer personnalisés
sont le revers des armes biologiques personnalisées,
ce qui signifie qu'on peut attaquer un individu,
y compris toutes les personnes sur cette photo.
Comment les protègerons-nous dans l'avenir ?
Que faire ? Que faire pour tout ça ?
C'est ce qu'on me demande tout le temps.
Pour ceux d'entre vous qui me suivez sur Twitter,
je twitterai la réponse plus tard dans la journée. (Rires)
En fait, c'est un peu plus complexe que ça,
et il n'y a aucun miracle.
Je n'ai pas toutes les réponses,
mais je sais un certain nombre de choses.
Dans la foulée du 11 septembre,
les meilleurs cerveaux de la sécurité
ont mis en commun toute leur innovation
et voici ce qu'ils ont créé pour la sécurité.
Si vous pensez que les gens qui ont construit ça pour vous protéger
de la future robot-apocalypse , (Rires)
euh, vous pourriez vouloir avoir un plan B. (Rires)
Je dis ça, je dis rien. Pensez-y. (Applaudissements)
Le maintien de l'ordre est actuellement un système fermé.
Il est axé sur la nation, alors que la menace est internationale.
Le maintien de l'ordre ne progresse pas mondialement. Au moins, il ne l'a pas fait pour l'instant
et notre système actuel d'armes à feux, de gardes-frontières, de grandes portes et clôtures
est obsolète dans le nouveau monde dans lequel nous évoluons.
Alors comment pourrions-nous nous préparer à certaines de ces menaces spécifiques,
comme un attentant contre un président ou un premier ministre ?
Ce serait la réponse naturelle du gouvernement,
de cacher tous nos chefs de gouvernement
dans les bulles hermétiquement scellées.
Mais ça ne marchera pas.
Le coût de prodution d'une séquence d'ADN sera ridicule.
Tout le monde l'aura et nous en aurons tous dans l'avenir.
Nous pouvons donc peut-être envisager ça plus radicalement.
Que se passerait-t-il si on prenait
l'ADN du Président, ou d'un roi ou d'une reine,
et on le confiait à un groupe de quelques centaines
de chercheurs de confiance afin qu'ils puissent
étudier cet ADN et le tester contre la pénétration
pour aider nos dirigeants ?
Et si on l'envoyait à quelques milliers de gens ?
Ou, de façon discutable et non sans risques,
que se passerait-il si on le donnait simplement à tout le public ?
Alors on pourrait tous être impliqués et contribuer.
Nous avons déjà vu des exemples qui ont bien marché.
Le Projet de rapport sur le crime organisé et la corruption,
se compose de journalistes et de citoyens
qui ont recours au crowd-sourcing
pour faire savoir ce que font les dictateurs et les terroristes
avec les fonds publics dans le monde entier,
et, dans un cas plus radical,
nous avons vu au Mexique,
un pays qui a connu
50 000 meurtres liés à la drogue
au cours des six dernières années.
Ils tuent tant de gens
qu'ils n'ont même plus les moyens de les enterrer tous
autrement que dans des tombes anonymes
comme ici en banlieue de Ciudad Juarez.
Que pouvons-nous y faire ? Le gouvernement s'est avéré inefficace.
Alors, au Mexique, les citoyens prennent de grands risques
et se battent pour construire une solution efficace.
Ils cartographient les activités des trafiquants de drogue collaborativement.
Que vous vous en rendiez compte ou non
nous sommes à l'aube d'une course à l'armement technologique,
une course aux armements entre les gens
qui utilisent la technologie pour le bien
et ceux qui l'utilisent pour le mal.
La menace est sérieuse et il est maintenant temps de s'y préparer.
Je peux vous assurer que les terroristes et les criminels le font.
Je suis personnellement convaincu que
plutôt que d'avoir une petite armée d'élite
d'agents du gouvernement hautement qualifiés
ici pour nous protéger tous,
nous ferions beaucoup mieux
d'avoir des citoyens ordinaires et moyens
qui abordent ce problème en groupe
et voient ce que nous pouvons faire.
Si nous faisons tous notre part,
je pense que nous serons dans un bien meilleur espace.
Les outils pour changer le monde
sont entre les mains de tout le monde.
Comment nous les utilisons ne dépend pas que de moi,
mais de nous tous.
Il s'agit d'une technologie que je déployais souvent
quand j'étais officier de police.
Cette technologie est devenue désuète dans notre monde actuel.
Elle ne s'adapte pas assez, elle ne fonctionne pas à l'échelle mondiale,
et elle ne fonctionne pas virtuellement.
Nous avons vu que le paradigme se déplace dans le crime et le terrorisme.
Ils appellent à un changement vers une forme plus ouverte
et une forme plus participative du maintien de l'ordre.
Je vous invite donc à vous joindre à moi.
Après tout, la sécurité publique est trop importante pour la laisser aux professionnels.
Merci. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)